bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 et
sur radio france internationale pour une
interview avec le ministre des affaires
étrangères du niger hassoumi massaoudou
bonjour monsieur le ministre un jeu et
avec moi pour cette interview christophe
boisbouvier de rfi monsieur le ministre
bonjour bonjour monsieur le ministre le
président français emmanuel macron a
annoncé le départ du mali des forces de
l'opération barkan et de l'opération
takouba il a estimé que cela prendrait
de quatre à six mois ce vendredi la
junte a réagi en gelant site invitant la
france à retirer sans délai les troupes
de barkan et de takouba quelle est votre
réaction à ce qu'on peut appeler une
mise en demeure aux joies des réactions
cela soit je m'en tiens au fait que en
toute responsabilité
ces forces là quitter le mali de manière
ordonnée
c'est tout ce que j'ai commentaires je
n'ai connu par contre
ce calendrier nous nous connaissons ce
que ça va donner pour le niger est à
dire que vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons une accalmie à la frontière du
mali la nôtre de lenoir tillabéri nous
avons une accalmie parce que de l'autre
côté de la frontière vous savez que nous
n'avons pas de force manière nous
n'avons pas d'armes et mariam de ce côté
là les frontières nous avons l'armée
française et les groupes terroristes
l'armée française au québec et les
groupes terroristes et aujourd'hui nous
avons une accalmie sur cette zone à
cause du travail efficace mené par deux
coups bas et par barka est évidemment
leur retrait va entraîner une pression
plus importante sur nous alors
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons l'essentiel de
nos forces vers la frontière burkinabè
parce que l'action des forces françaises
et des forces européennes nous a permis
d'avoir la carmi l'action efficace bien
sûr
donc cela va entraîner forcé ma
une clé sur plus grande surtout si ce
sont des bons sens
je m'en tiens au fait que des troupes se
déplacent de manière responsable je
m'attends pas et je ne souhaite pas
faire de commentaires là dessus je ne
crois pas que des gens qui n'existent
pas de saison pourrait les faire partir
ça ne l'est donc nous nous avons de
notre côté de la frontière
cette pression de la qui va s'accroître
et nous pensons que cela nous commandent
assurer davantage avoir un souci encore
plus fort de la sécurité de notre pays
la frontière
du mali avec miami cette zone où se
trouvent les combattants de les ges les
terroristes c'est à dessein que le
gagnant
de ce côté c'est vers le burkina les
combattants du logis est que se trouve
au burkina sont à moins de 100 km de
niamey ça me donne une responsabilité
plus grande vous comprenez que pour nous
la défense de cette zone est une
priorité absolue la responsabilité du
président de la république et le
gouvernement c'est d'assurer données la
sécurité aux populations c'est ça notre
responsabilité et c'est pourquoi nous
appelons tout allié tous ceux qui
viendront nous renforcer et renforcer
notre sécurité sur cette ligne et que
les forces européennes et françaises
viennent jouer un rôle de cordon
sanitaire sur cette frontière là avec le
vide qui serait créée dans cet espace là
il va de soi que cela augmente notre
sécurité sur une zone où nous tenons qui
a 200 km de la ville de niamey la
capitale du pays mais est ce que la
junte quand même ne se bat pas contre
les djihadistes est-ce que vous avez
l'impression qu'ils veulent peut-être
discuter avec eux avec le départ des
français dans cette zone et va de soi
que les terroristes se serait un appel
d'air pour eux donc par conséquent nous
aura une pression nouvelle renouvelée
sur cette frontière l'arrivée des
français de ce côté-ci de la frontière
permettra certainement de
renforcer le cordon sanitaire par
rapport en fait
à ce sanctuaire curieuse que constitue
le nord-mali alors de l'autre côté de la
frontière maintenant il valait il va y
avoir des combattants russes et le pari
dont le mali ne sont pas nous les avons
pas vus et le pari de bamako c'est que
ces combattants russes vont réussir là
où les soldats français ont échoué
excuses à la propagande que nous
subissons j'ai entendu des gens dire au
niger peut attentions les chefs
djihadistes sont déjà au niger chassés
par les combattants russes ils sont
ailleurs où les y aident à gali et tout
ça sont un territoire géré c'est pour
vous dire que beaucoup de choses se
raconte sur les plus grotesques de ce
côté-ci de la frontière ni nouvelle ni
combat taurus n'y allons malienne je ne
sais pas ce que le ferrand les
combattants russes ce qu'il viendrait
faire ces mercenaires comment il se
comportera et que soit leur résultat
nous nous occupons de la sécurité de nos
populations tout cas vous et vous en
doutez delà de l'efficacité des russes
nous n'avons pas nous avons des
mercenaires qui n'ont pas de
responsabilité internationale c'est un
phénomène nouveau dans notre espace et
nous pensons que cela a sur le plan
éthique et sur le plan diplomatique sur
le plan de la paix dans la région et de
l'organisation de deux de la
responsabilité des états sait déjà
qu'une route les responsabilités
vis-à-vis de qui que ce soit qui sont
des forces irrégulières et des forces
nouvelles dans cet espace que nous ne
connaissons pas et le communiqué de la
cedeao les chefs d'état de la cedeao
marqué notre préoccupation par rapport à
la présence de ce type de force de notre
espace alors il nous en sommes
solidaires alors en parlant de forces
régulières
le départ de takouba et de de barkan ils
sont tous y laissant des ça veut dire
que des milliers de soldats français
vont désormais s'installer nouveau niger
je connais pas le nomme dans le
président 2500 mailly je ne connais pas
le nomme les questions seront discutées
manade maniériste arrco l'articulation
du nom de nom de structuration qui est
en train de se faire les discussions
sont engagées avec
les autorités militaires du niger et
puis les autorités militaires des autres
pays de la sous région pour voir comment
les articuler pour le moment c'est dans
le principe nous dans le principe nous
sommes prêts à accueillir les forces
européennes des forces spéciales
européennes y compris françaises sur
notre territoire et nous pensons et nous
le faisons en toute responsabilité nous
pensons qu'elles contribueront contenu
du vide qui sera créé et de l'autre côté
à renforcer avec nos forces à renforcer
nos capacités de défense pour assurer la
sécurité de nos populations alors fin
2021 à terra novembre un convoi
militaire français a été prise à partie
violemment par des civils il a eu trois
civils nigériens tués donc y est ce que
en amenant peut-être pas des milliers
mais en tout cas des centaines de
soldats français des bases
supplémentaires française que vous ne
prenez pas un risque politique parce que
le sentiment anti français pourrait être
exacerbée vous savez ce qu'on a dit aux
jeunes de terrain on avait dit que les
le convoi français qui était c'était le
31e convoi ou 33e quelque chose comme ça
c'est certain qu'on voie habituelle mais
cette fois ci ce qu'on voit à porter des
armes pour les terroristes et les gens
ont connu tout à l'heure je vous disais
que les gens en plus qui elle était en
territoire nigérien de la ville
d'ailleurs ou parce qu'il a été chassé
par les russes vous voyez comment la
puissance et l'effet dévastateur rapide
de certains types de communication en ce
qui concerne le sentiment anti français
d'abord premièrement nous n'avons pas
actuellement d'accords de défense avec
qui que ce soit des accords de défense
suppose que il y est
quand un pays est attaqué l'autre vient
à sa rescousse ici il s'agit d'une
entreprise commune de lutte contre le
terrorisme que nous menons avec beaucoup
de pays y compris européens comme
africains nous avons signé des accords
de coopération avec les accords de
coopération dessus sur la sécurité avec
l'allemagne avec les états unis avec la
france et les mêmes types d'accords de
coopération qu'on a signés et ces
accords là ne sont pas sont tels qu'ils
sont c'est des accords de défense qui
sont soumis au parlement cela non cela
ne sont pas super mais pour cette fois
ci contenu
de la propagande qui est menée à propos
du sentiment anti français à propos du
peuple nigérien qui serait contre la
présence de forces étrangères sur notre
pays le plaisant la république malgré
bien qu'il n'ait pas l'obligation de
saisir le parlement a demandé au premier
ministre d'engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement au parlement sur cette
question donc cela serait 5 sur elle des
parlementaires qui sera sanctionné par
un vote et le gouvernement engagerait sa
responsabilité
donc voilà ce qu'on se reverra la
représentation nationale ces salaires le
besoin de le publier nous sommes un pays
démocratique et où l'exercice
démocratique se ferait dans l'enceinte
privilégié pour l'expression
démocratique des soldes des
représentants du peuple et puis
maintenant les gens verront ce que
pensera le plus plaisir dans ce qu'ils
en pensent donc voilà nous sommes dans
un pays démocratique et la démocratie
s'exprimera par rapport à cela nous
engageons notre responsabilité sur cette
question et donc dans votre commentaire
voilà le niger est un pays démocratique
mais l'afrique de l'ouest est frappé par
une contagion de coup d'état muée votre
pays en a connu quatre depuis
l'indépendance il a connu une dernière
tentative en avril dernier est ce que
vous prenez ce risque au sérieux mais
disons que ce jusqu'au que toujours
existé bien entendu c'est cucul il y est
mais le coup d'état n'est jamais une
question technique c'est toujours une
question politique et nous nous savons
nous savons que les conditions
de les conditions actuelles au nigeria
les conditions d'expression
démocratiques de fonctionnement de nos
institutions la solidité de nos
associant est telle que nous ne pensons
pas que le peuple nigérien et un
sentiment de régime au point où
cela créerait des circonstances
favorables vous de ce qui s'est passé au
mali les deux trois putschs clients
depuis 2012 c'est la faillite totale de
l'état fasse un pays qui a produit le dr
de son territoire au burkina faso c'est
aussi un pays vous savez bien que le
présent kaboré le groupe franchement pas
la corruption le népotisme quoi que ce
soit c'est la faillite
l'incapacité de l'occupation la perte de
contrôle pratiquement du nord et de
l'est de son territoire qui a fait que
cette armée elle même qui était
seulement est venu prendre le pouvoir en
disant que c'était un peu textant de
l'incapacité d'assurer ses côtés chez
nous au niger il n'y a pas de
sanctuaires terroristes dans notre pays
voilà pourquoi nous n'avons pas nous ne
partageons pas les mêmes situations que
le mali qui n'a pas de contrôle sur les
deux tiers de son territoire au club
burkina où il ya eu un effondrement il
faut le dire et du nord de ce pays et
c'est les mêmes armés qui ont échoué qui
viennent clore le pouvoir je sais pas si
elles pourront répondre à lhassa la
guerre comme n'ont pas pu mener rien
donc voilà un peu mais nous n'avons pas
nous ne présentons pas les mêmes
caractéristiques
ensuite nous voulons prouver que nous
allons nous pouvions nous sommes en
train de le prouver qu'on peut être un
état démocratique un état où
fonctionnent des institutions là je
viens de parler de saisine du parlement
et
un état stable qui peut aussi en plus
dans une relation intelligente et
responsable avec des partenaires
africains comme l'européen vaincre le
terrorisme
merci monsieur le ministre de nous avoir
accordé cet entretien et merci à vous de
nous avoir suivi sur nos deux chaînes
france 24 et radio france internationale
[Musique]